hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and uh despite the trippy appearance of
this menu we are going to be looking at
something very very closely because we
need to see if something's going to
change welcome to I'm on observation
duty 5. if you're confused the last one
I played was four and I never played
three two or one and I'm not going to
probably one each sharp eyes and a good
memory to survive I'm not even relying
on you so you better pay close attention
and then tell me in the past about how I
was in the future when you're watching
this in the past but either way we got
school Metro Market apartment house Bank
let's go school
why not man that was a weird weird menu
the anomalies keep appearing
even after his demise we received
reports of a haunted school please take
care of it
instructions will be provided
I'm sure they will be
are they being provided are the
instructions being oh
this might be the instructions attention
employee anomalies have been previously
cited in the monitored area pay
extremely close attention to the
surveillance camera footage
file an anomaly report ASAP when you
notice something has changed
okay sounds good I knew what to do
anyway so we got
wow okay so we gotta have this presence
still don't know what that means camera
malfunction Distortion door open and
closing extra object Intruder light
anomaly object disappearance optic
movement picture anomaly other TV
monitor anomaly
I don't know why there got to be so many
different anomalies but let's
get to it oh God I'm gonna have to
remember the balls I gotta remember the
saddle horse or whatever it is pommel
horse I gotta remember the logos
oh no I'm doomed
oh I'm doomed
oh these are just weird paint what is
that what I'm gonna report that I'm
reporting you
there's no way that's conducive for
student learning
picture anomaly boom
yeah that's weird I don't like that
weird stretched out flesh no type no
anomaly
you're trying to
test had to look at that nightmare well
whatever that is unless it's something
normal and I'm not
seeing what it looks awful
whatever it is it's horrendous okay
maybe nothing changes before I have a
chance to look at it I don't know
okay so we're back to the beginning I
was not paying attention to this area so
I don't really remember what it looked
like I'm scanning
okay looks the same ish I think oh man I
don't know
um
it's just that thing where you kind of
trick yourself into thinking there are
two bottles of water there is that
important probably one projector it's a
like an Empire symbol from Star Wars
there
uh
um I don't know why I feel like I need
to be quiet but I feel like I need to be
very quiet
this is too quiet
what
did I miss something this is an
emergency warning
we are receiving readings of multiple
active anomalies in your area please
locate the anomaly
anomalies but I was doing that
what do you mean what do you mean
multiple multiple multiple what do you
mean multiple
I don't know what you're talking about
wait was that door always was that wait
wait wait door door um Corridor uh
Corridor crew Corridor crew is an
anomaly uh door door
is that it
says
[Music]
whoa that wasn't there okay report
um classroom one extra object that was
not there before this that was
definitely not there before
I think
no no what is wrong with you
don't marry this woman wait a minute
toilet
uh picture anomaly
okay got that I bet that that's that's
that is the one that's the one
fixing anomaly
thanks how did you fix it I don't even
know how you fixed it do I even want to
know how you fixed it I do that's why I
asked shut up can be
right can't be who refuses to be right
there's gotta be another anomaly here
but I wasn't paying attention close
enough before
so I don't really remember
anything I'm just gonna be like oh no
God
I was just gonna say maybe there's an
extra object in classroom too I don't
know
just to see
because there probably was something
here but I just didn't know what it was
because I wasn't making attention enough
to it
no extra
I better move thing maybe something got
moved
maybe maybe object movement that's
probably a pretty safe bet if I wasn't
paying attention enough
no not only what about classroom one
movement
uh I don't know if I get penalized for
false reports
I probably do
damn
gym
moved object the hardest one of these is
is missing object because if I never saw
it in the first place I would never
notice that it was gone
God I don't know why I didn't learn my
lesson from last time and just like
blast through the cameras and look at
what I was doing instead of just being
an [__] and not doing anything this
is how I always get myself in trouble
because I don't know what the hell I'm
doing
[Laughter]
oh man
I'm I'm out of here no I'm not going
back to that give me give me somewhere
else give me the Metro give me the
goddamn Metro
bodak we received reports of a haunted
station you might hear announcements of
incoming train traffic do not mistake
these four anomalies instructions will
be provided well I think I know the
instructions are probably the same okay
looking looking I am looking at you
looking looking how is that normal how
could that possibly be normal looking
looking I am why is that normal
champion
this is not normal
it's not normal guys it's a normal not
normal okay Pizza
crash nobody
were those moving
they probably were but just in case
entrance
object movement just in case
I don't think it was
no
I gotta go through these quicker so they
stay in my mind
so I can picture them in my mind's eye
so I can visit all my friends
I don't know Lobby
extra object see I I wasn't good at this
before
whoa whoa hey
whoa hey oh when you when you said
object movement I didn't mean you
literally that it literally was moving
right then and there that that is much
more obvious
look at me
look at me knowing what I'm doing it was
that's okay
I like you
whoa that's a new one hey I would
remember there being a new friend here
you know you don't get to be here
[Music]
I'm interested
they're Abyss presence
there is no way that I did not notice
that face there am I crazy
or there is no way that was there
there is no way
there is no way other I'm just gonna say
other because I don't like it
there's no way I cannot be that
unobservant
oh my God it was there it was there the
whole time how did I not see that
I hate that I hate that
I hate that
there's got to be another one already
foreign
this feels like there's more stuff on
wait a minute
saw that
so there's got to be another anomaly
here that I'm not noticing
but they are very difficult to notice
oh God why does it do that oh
this is making me look like an idiot are
you guys screaming at me
better not be so many of you think you
might see something and you might be
wrong
and it doesn't count if you pause the
video and you're able to compare just
take a screenshot it's not that's not
how this works
understand how this works
I have what what it's over
oh you I fixed two and it ended sooner
than the last one
I don't know what's normal
I suppose I would know it's normal if I
actually didn't just hop from place to
place do not seek the secret it will
come to you
what does that even mean
what does that mean the boss went
shopping yesterday
and found anomalous activity in the
supermarket
the site has been contained
do your job
instructions will be provided yeah I bet
they will be
okay so instruction will be provided
okay this seems more manageable
unless it's different I don't know
foreign
somewhat more contained
who
it seems like there's less stuff here
than there was in aisle one
missing
uh oh there oh No Object disappearance
okay
whoa that's there was definitely not an
ax in aisle two I can 100 say for sure
and that they didn't sell axes next to
semaji
thank you
that seems strange I don't remember that
being there maybe it's been there
produce extra object
Maybe
ah hey all right
yeah I imagine that they probably
wouldn't start with object
disappearances
because that would be silly
because how would you know if you don't
know the area enough
Gotta Give me a chance you know
I feel like I gotta Bob my head like a
chicken to be able to actually force my
brain to look at the different spots
here or else I'm just gonna be
wallowing in the same mistakes that I've
always made
these are the same that picture's the
same
good father always like that I don't
know why did I get such a big screen I
sometimes think my hair is a movement
but it's not
bobbin in the corner of my eye
but I did good two in the first hour
that's got to be some kind of a record
I can't
be sure
whoa that's different I remember when I
looked at the bar
there is an extra object in Frozen a
wrench who keeps putting this crap here
get it out of here
all right this is great this is good I
seem to be getting a read on it it seems
to be kind enough
ah the freaking hour thing don't do that
okay and I seem to be getting a good
read on it I think the market is going
to be my my bread and butter
it's not even a joke God lyxian blow up
the entire video
oh break room
break room uh object uh
other I don't know
the fan turned off how do you even
categorize that
I don't hey okay other counts I guess
okay but so far I haven't gotten the
alert that there are multiple anomalies
I mean that's probably a good sign right
that means that I'm doing something
right
I'm on the right track everybody I'm on
the right track wait a minute
what what what
that what no
maybe I'm just thinking about a fan and
I never noticed how would I have never
noticed that
what I did notice that
what
okay so there was a fan here is that
what I'm
thank you I'm not crazy
there was a fan there I don't remember
that I don't
I don't know how I didn't notice that
this is crazy the things that you just
can't see physically I can even see it
there
I can see it there I swear I would have
seen that fan
am I nutso
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh check out object
disappearance there were water bottles
right here
I'm doing good
I'm doing good I've got like six or
something anomalies
that's got to be good right that's got
to be good It's gotta be good I would
never be able to notice if something
disappeared in here I don't think I
would ever notice I don't know how I
would notice
what's with this weird black disc
that was there right
Abyss presence
wrong yes I know I was gonna do another
here as well
oh the
zucchini's the zucchinis
the zucchinis are floating unless those
are carrots and lemons
that cannot be right
all right good
to fix that
easy
I still haven't gotten the
multiple anomaly things so somehow
I'm dialed in
to the max
somehow
don't know how
oh
God you scared me
you scared me
don't do that well that one was obvious
oh why wasn't everything else obvious it
probably was obviously
nope nope are you sure about that oh
it's a door
really
okay it's a door it's a freaking door
right okay
whatever
a little on edge it's fine I don't think
you can blame me for that I wonder if
it's gonna be like
phasmaphobia where I gotta suss out the
type of ghost that it is
probably not
something seemed different about this
picture
it's not drastic
there's just a thought a thread in the
back of my mind
no no it's fine
um I feel like I'm missing something
I feel like I'm missing something I feel
like something's slipping by me
ah shootie
I feel like I'm missing something
I feel like it's been too long
I'm missing it oh God It's gotta be
there
oh what am I missing what am I missing I
don't know
oh ah is there something missing from
aisle one
aisle one object disappearance Maybe
oh I know I know I know
I know it's an emergency
I'm aware of this
I know I know I just I do you see it I
don't see it
I don't see anything
oh say anything at all
oh
[__]
how about uh aisle one extra object I
don't know extra uh
[Music]
oh God uh Pro well I meant to check out
but whatever I'm dead I'm done so
there's no wait a minute the ladder the
ladder the ladder Frozen object
disappearance the ladder
the ladder's gone I knew something was
facing
There's Hope okay I gotta find the other
one there's gotta be another one here
right there's got to be another one
that's fine that's fine still that that
that's fine that's fine this is all fine
uh uh uh
uh aisle two uh
wait a minute what is that picture
anomaly I don't remember there being
something all the way up there
um here there's gotta be like a missing
object here
It's gotta be like
produce has to have some kind of
object disappearance I don't know
oh my God it did
oh oh picture anomaly oh we got hope we
got hope we got hope we have hope what
am I looking at I don't even know I
don't know what disappeared from produce
wait a minute there's pills there why
that produce has
extra object that's I know that's not
right I very much know that's not right
okay so I I've done like four this is
like the fourth anomaly that I somehow
got so I I'm good now I should be caught
up maybe
this has been that empty before so
that's fine
break room is still okay
that's there maybe it was that that was
missing before I don't know
that's gone now
fine
I'm going to say aisle 2 just in case
what did I just see
no
whoa my God no thank you there's a
picture on Emily uh can you not whatever
the hell you're doing can you not do
that thing that you're doing now that
would be great that would be just great
thank you
please don't look at me like that ever
again
wonderful good oh
oh
movement in aisle two man I never would
have seen that
if I hadn't been exactly here
normally fix there
oh oh what is whoa what what is what is
uh abyss of the obviously Abyss the
abyss the abyss Abyss Abyss
[Music]
okay I finally found the abyss everybody
um you know it turns out it's exactly
what you thought it would be a gaping
hole into nothingness an expanding blood
hole in reality
this is what it is
oh gong four damn I've never made it
this far I don't think I've ever made it
this far I am doing wonderfully
I feel very confident in myself and my
own abilities I'm gonna just do a just
in case object disappearance here
because I would never know something
does seem like it might be missing from
here
but probably not but just in case
oh I'm missing something
I'm missing something again
it's been too long without finding one
definitely has been too long sure you're
fine this is fine
maybe object missing
um I'll two
well oh just stop uh cease oh my God
wait a minute in the produce there's
there's an uh an intruder there there is
an intro
look at me don't look at me nice shoes
don't
yeah why were you deep-throating the
banana why are you deep throating the
banana
why would you do that
that was entirely unnecessary
please never do it again
thank you
oh freaking you don't deserve one
you're getting two for the price of one
hello
great
good
let me go back to my chicken dance good
I'm getting two for the phase one
hooray
oh that's open okay Frozen
would that be a door opening
I don't know maybe
okay okay
thank you for counting that as a door
coffee was not full in the break room
it's weird how I would know that
um
I'm just gonna say other it's the coffee
that cup was empty
it did got it thank you I do appreciate
that that is very nice of you
whoa Distortion Distortion aisle 2 has a
distortion that's definitely there's
that that I am surprised that I actually
noticed that but there definitely is
and I hear it you can hear that
okay good
that's an odd one
I've also been constantly looking at
this shiny Vaz over there
I'm just gonna do a produce a produce
objects and disappearance just because
five o'clock that's good
never done that before
[Music]
whoa cold flesh awesome
uh
would be picture anomaly I guess
I guess maybe okay all right thank you I
hope they just like consider these on
under multiple different categories
because
it would be difficult
be difficult to discern
whoa the wall is different and Frozen
what
yeah was it
I'm not crazy Rick okay I was about to
say am I crazy these things like
the changes are like am I crazy wait was
the break room always this texture as
well
was the breaker I'm always this I don't
think it
am I crazy
no
has it always been like that uh I I
guess it has
oh man now I think I'm I think I'm
losing my mind
I'm gonna just say because it's been a
while produce objects disappearance
because that's my default I just say
that because if it's right then that's
good
it's wrong then I'm well light anomaly
light anomaly and check out check out
flight anomaly
okay that's good
it feels good good fixing anomaly
I'm doing wonderfully
I'm doing so good I'm doing I see now
I'm like there's no way these walls were
walls like this here
there's no way
he looks like something super weird in
there
but I've been looking at this the whole
time I've never taken in the texture of
the walls why would anybody do that why
would anybody what about that is that
fruit is that a fruit that better be
fruit
I have a better be a fruit
I'm just gonna say maybe missing object
I don't know
oh light anomaly in aisle one
some kind of weirdness
that's fun that's fun Ah that's fun
it's kind of cute it's kind of cute
oh check out there's an intruder there's
an intruder there's an intruder there's
an intruder it's the cider man
I don't like him
yeah uh you you guys come later we
haven't opened yet
how hungry you are
all right please let this say this ends
at 6 00 am
please let it be Five Nights at Freddy's
style because I don't think I've ever
actually won
and I've been I've been on it I've been
freaking on it
man I've been on it I haven't dude
excellently
I'm not seeing anything
I'm missing something
what am I missing
am I doing it
oh
yes oh my God have I ever done that I
don't even know if I've ever done that
have I ever done that how did I do that
oh my God how did I do that
I fixed twenty five
holy crap
well there you have it
boy
boy do I remember
[Music]
no
after this the bureau was formed okay
we will accomplish work with us let's
concludes the history briefing
[Music]
oh that's good to know
um Well I this is gonna make me puke
thank you okay that's good well thank
you everybody so much for watching um
that was observation Duty 5. I'm getting
really good at it so if you want me to
play this again I know that there's a
deeper Secret in all of this just
waiting to be discovered by these
peepers so keep your peepers peeled and
thank you for watching now I'm going to
stay here for the end of this video and
you just notice if any changes happen
the camera will change a few times but
just be aware no changes are really
happening maybe but if you see them
report them in the comments below
thank you